The skill itself is being able
to detach during the event,
the Hartford Huston notice,
you got to look for those signs.
You've got to look for that moment.
When you start feeling emotional or you
know that it's going to be something
emotionally,
you've got to step back from those and
get dig yourself in the habit of asking
yourself, what do I look like right
now? What do I sound like right now?
Listen to the words that are coming out
of your mouth and see if you're being a
reasonable human or not.
Look for the emotional quicksand and
don't step in at the emotion of the anger,
the frustration. When you start
feeling the sweat beading up,
when you start feeling hot, that
should be a big red flag. There it is.
That's the quicksand of emotion.
You don't want to step into it.
Pull yourself back.